the chief Constable of police Scotland
sir Ian Livingston has admitted publicly
that his force is institutionally racist
sexist misogynistic and discriminatory
he made the admission at a meeting of
the Scottish police Authority in a
statement he said I know and have shared
the reservations and concerns about
acknowledging that institutional
discrimination exists in policing
however he says it is right for me the
right thing to do is Chief Constable to
clearly state that institutional racism
sexism misogyny and discrimination exist
at least Scotland is institutionally
racist and discriminatory publicly
acknowledging these institutional issues
exists is essential to our absolute
commitment to championing equality and
becoming an anti-racist service it's
also critical in our determination to
lead wider change in society he goes on
to say that the onus is on us the Police
Service to address gaps and challenge
bias no not unwitting at every level
wherever that occurs
to maintain and build confidence with
all communities recognizing
institutional discrimination
institutional racism in my view is a
statement of reality the real challenge
the real test is how we are working to
address it what we are doing about it so
really strong words
from police Scotland's Chief Constable
setting out his belief that the service
in Scotland is institutionally racist
and misogynistic and discriminatory